I'm honored to be able to stand
before all of you, extremely
humbled to be able
to stand here today.
Recently, I wrote to Chief
DiFava and several members
of the MIT police department.
I wanted them to know that I
had been keeping all police
officers in my
thoughts and prayers.
I told them, as I
will tell you, that I
know that this is a
difficult time for all of us.
And judging by our
numbers here today,
and by the intensive
conversations
that we have shared,
I also know that it
has been extremely hard for us
to continuously witness-- even
from a distance-- the tragic
deaths of innocent men
and women.
Often, black men and
women, as well as
the tragic deaths of
police officers committed
to their profession; officers
who were fulfilling their duty
to protect and serve.
On this latter
point, I would like
to make a declarative statement.
But in doing so, I
acknowledge that I
am taking a liberty, a liberty
that will enable me to attempt
to speak for most black people.
And speaking for most, not
to mention all black people,
is not something
that I take lightly.
But today, I take this
liberty because I truly
believe that I
stand with most when
I say that as black
people specifically,
we believe that what
happened in Dallas was wrong.
It was heartbreaking.
It was a grave injustice in
the face of so many others.
And most of us would not only
agree with Dr. King's words,
we would espouse them
as our personal beliefs.
"Returning violence for
violence multiplies violence,
adding deeper darkness to a
night already devoid of stars.
Darkness cannot drive
out darkness," he says,
"only light can do that.
Hate cannot drive out hate,
only love can do that."
Clearly, feelings of
helplessness, hurt, anger,
and rage have been
expressed here today;
feelings that many
of us in this room
have been concealing and
holding in for far too long.
These feelings are
genuine, and in many ways,
unavoidable, and
certainly undeniable.
We need and deserve
time to grieve.
Life, however, has
taught me that if we
stay in a state of
helplessness too long,
it can and will cloud our
vision, our perspective,
and our reality.
Because in reality,
we as individuals,
and certainly we as the MIT
community, are not helpless.
For MIT is renowned in
name, many in numbers,
powerful in presence, and
virtually unparalleled
in our capacity to solve the
world's greatest challenges.
In fact, when it comes to
solving the world's greatest
problems, the world
often looks to us.
In the space called
problem-solving,
MIT sits in a unique and
often unrivaled position.
So my MIT family, I do not
believe that we are helpless,
because only a university
with a president who
is confident in its ability to
positively impact and influence
social, political,
and economic change
would challenge itself,
its students, its faculty,
its staff, and its alumni
to make a better world.
As a nation I do
not believe that we
are incapable of rising
above our current state.
We can seek peace.
We can implement legislation
policies, practices,
and a level of democratic
and community policing
that will not only
heal our land,
but increase trust and create
an environment that ensures
safety and security for all.
So today, I urge us not
to give into the darkness,
the darkness of doubt and fear.
Instead, let us
embrace the light
that shines so
brightly within each
of our hearts and our minds.
For it has been said that
our deepest fear is not
that we are inadequate,
our deepest fear
is that we are powerful
beyond measure.
It is our light,
not our darkness,
that most frightens us.
And that light, my friends,
that life-giving, life-changing,
infinitely powerful and
brilliantly fueled light
is not just in some of us, it
is in each and every one of us.
So we must boldly and
responsibly shine our lights.
We must carry our torches,
our lanterns, our beacons,
our light sabers.
We must carry them
as symbols of hope
and use them for
good, for they will
be a lamp unto our feet,
illuminating the pathway that
will enable us to
truly see one another,
to respect one another,
to love one another,
and to stand together as
one-- to stand together
against injustice,
intolerance, and hatred.
Our lights must shine so bright
that others will not only
see our great dome
in Killian Court,
but they will see
our good works,
and they will be inspired to
pick up their torches as well.
And finally, we
must use the power
of the light that is harnessed
within us to eradicate
the darkness that attempts
to cloak individuals
and systems that perpetuate
racism, oppression,
and violence against any group.
MIT, we have been called
for such a time as this.
We are the chosen, for we are
called to make a better world.
I will do my part,
will you do yours?
Will you do your part
to make a better world?
Thank you for being here today.
[AUDIENCE APPLAUSE]